There are35 types of cancer
that may be related to mold.
Taiwan is very humid.
There have been typhoons and floods recently.
People living in this environment
actually have mycotoxin levels in their bodies
that are also particularly high.
Very common symptoms.
Can you give us a few examples?
People who have strange reactions to eating sulfides.
For example, garlic, onions,
and even cruciferous vegetables.
These sound super healthy to us,
great foods.
It means that somewhere in your body,
there must be mold.
Nasal allergies.
Whether it's allergic rhinitis or sinusitis.
Cognitive impairment or dementia, brain fog.
It can cross the BBB (blood-brain barrier).
Its function is to prevent
anything dangerous from getting into the brain.
But mycotoxins can actually
go straight through.
Hi everyone, I'm Dr. Wen-Hsin.
Did you know?
Many people's health problems,
for example, fatigue,
feeling tired all day for no reason,
and constant allergies,
chronic inflammation,
and the most common in my clinic is
yo-yo dieting.
But,
there is a major hidden reason
that you might not know about until now.
Mycotoxins.
Wow, speaking of such a professional topic,
I've invited my good friend,
Dr. Wang Wei-Chuan from the UltraClinic.
Dr. Wang Wei-Chuan from the Ultra Clinic
to share with us.
Let's welcome him.
Thank you, Wen-Hsin.
I'm very happy.
In Taiwan, we are in a humid,
mold-filled environment.
I don't think
it would have any major impact on me.
Until I went to a class
and the journal "Cell" indicated
there are  35 types of cancer
that may be related to mold.
And in these cancer patients,
can  actually find mold DNA embedded inside.
Then I found it strange.
I don't eat any moldy food.
If I see mold, I definitely throw it away.
Yes.
So how do they get into my body and affect me?
One of our cases was someone who
ate some dried tofu.
Only after he finished did he realize
that the rest of it at the bottom seemed to be moldy.
Actually, the air
is also full of mold spores.
However,  mycotoxins
are actually odorless.
So, does that mean
even if I don't see it,
or even if I can't smell it,
it's still possible that through diet
or inhaling mold from the environment.
then, mycotoxins are produced,
or mold spores enter our  body?
Wait a minute.
I think I have a very basic question.
Mold,
mold spores,
mycotoxins,
They are different things.
Mycotoxins are not alive.
Mycotoxins are metabolic products of mold spores.
They are secreted only
under stressful conditions.
And it  is fat-soluble.
So it will accumulate in your body's
various adipose tissues.
So it's very difficult to excrete.
And being fat-soluble has another, more troublesome aspect.
It attacks mitochondria.
It penetrates deep into cells
and causes chronic fatigue,
and chronic inflammation.
Then it produces oxidative stress.
And you said mold produces toxins
under stressful conditions.
Is this a way for them to survive in nature?
Actually, some studies have found
that mold in the natural environment
doesn't necessarily produce mycotoxins.
It's when there is stress,
for example, when other organisms
try to invade its territory,
that it will secrete these mycotoxins.
When it enters our modern environment,
for example, these reinforced concrete buildings,
or bathrooms and kitchens,
or air conditioning systems,
or our own bodies,
our immune systems will attack them.
Second is the modern dietary environment.
Regarding food,
all kinds of snacks and processed foods.
To mold,
is a likely stressful environment.
Very harsh.
A very harsh environment that is unfriendly to it.
So it starts to produce large amounts of mycotoxins.
Let's think about
if there are any hidden places in our homes
that could be their hiding spots
that we need to pay attention to.
Because Taiwan is very humid.
And now we have typhoons,
and floods, and all sorts of things.
In this environment,
people living in water-damaged buildings,
the level of mycotoxins in their bodies
is also particularly high.
So the first thing is to find out,
of course, any water leaks,
any wall mold,
any mold spots.
Some people, when they flip over their sofa,
or flip over their mattress,
or their washing machine,
then they find a lot of mold inside.
And for some people, it's the air conditioning system.
And one case was an indoor potted plant.
The soil of indoor potted plants also needs to be maintained.
You have to till the soil regularly.
I've been wondering  about my house.
Which places need more cleaning?
What about food?
We don't necessarily see mold on our food.
Are there any foods that are
more likely to have hidden mold?
Generally speaking, it's still grains.
recently , there was the peanut butter case,
where aflatoxin was found inside.
And then there are
coffee beans.
Coffee beans are very scary.
Because I have friends who specialize in roasting beans,
and they have to pick out the defective beans themselves.
But he found many of them
were coffee beans eroded by mold.
These could contain mycotoxins.
In fact, some studies have found
that some can be analyzed in coffee beans.
Ochratoxin, aflatoxin,
and other such toxins.
And then there are
berries, which are particularly susceptible.
I recall that Dr. Wang,
you have been affected by mold.
That's right.
Your own symptoms and how you discovered them back then.
Actually, my first encounter with mycotoxins
was because I practice prolotherapy.
And I was because of
lots and lots of pain,
plus other accompanying symptoms.
For example, I had very severe fatigue.
And another thing is,
I've had a runny nose my whole life.
At first, I just thought,
could it be allergens?
But I tested for allergens and it seemed fine.
So I thought,
maybe there's something fishy going on.
Then later I met many, many masters.
And after talking with them, they felt that
my symptoms were more indicative of mycotoxins.
So that's how I embarked on this journey.
You've already mentioned some,
I think many people will resonate with these symptoms.
If we were to compile a list of some
obvious and very common symptoms,
could you give us a few?
I've compiled 5 major symptoms.
The first two are what I just mentioned.
Nasal allergies.
Whether it's allergic rhinitis or sinusitis.
The second is chronic fatigue.
Because it affects the mitochondria.
And the third one is
cognitive impairment or dementia, brain fog.
Because it is fat-soluble,
it can cross the BBB,
the blood-brain barrier.
This barrier in the brain
should actually be very strong.
Its function is to prevent
anything dangerous from getting into the brain.
But mycotoxins can actually
go straight through.
And there are even studies that have found
ochratoxin can reach the hippocampus,
which is our memory center.
So it actually will
affect our memory and concentration.
Next is chronic pain.
Like, why is it so painful,
and no matter the treatment, the effect is poor.
Then you have to consider if there are other reasons
causing chronic inflammation.
And the fifth one is rather special, it's tremors.
You've seen a neurologist,
and they tell you it's a bit like epilepsy,
dystonia, Parkinson's disease,
but it's atypical.
These tremor symptoms where the body shakes.
This could all be related to mycotoxins.
One is a bit like Parkinson's disease.
But another one, by a mycotoxin master
named Neil Nathan,
he mentioned in his book
a very special kind of tremor,
called "internal vibration."
Which is an internal tremor.
He says it comes from the spinal cord.
Wow, I think these symptoms are really
very nonspecific.
But,
I think in weight loss cases,
I also have a memorable case.
He just couldn't lose weight.
And he was actually already eating healthily,
and he was also exercising.
I thought,
well, why don't we test for mycotoxins?
And I actually caught it.
Then I first used some nutritional therapy,
and some things to improve mitochondrial function,
including IV drips.
And then
hey, his weight started to budge.
But I think he was also very...
you could say, very diligent.
Once he knew about this,
he  did a major cleanup of his house.
During a class,
I asked Dr. Jill Crista about this,
and she said, indeed,
she also found that in her clinic
many people who repeatedly try to lose weight
and failed.
I think it might be related to what we just said,
that toxins are fat-soluble.
That is related.
Because our fat wants to encapsulate the toxins.
So if I lose weight today,
but the mycotoxins are still there,
then our body's defense system
will naturally,
want to encapsulate it again.
Are there any other rather unique ones, like
if you have this symptom,
you would also have a high degree of suspicion?
One of them is frequent urination.
It's a bit like an overactive bladder.
Of course, for this, I would first ask them to see
a urologist or gynecologist.
But if they encounter some obstacles there,
I would really recommend they get tested for mycotoxins.
But why?
I think a major reason
might be related to Candidiasis .
It produces something called Gliotoxin.
Various mycotoxins,
no matter which type,
will affect our immune system.
And within our immune system,
there's something called TH2,
which is related to allergies and sensitivity.
Mycotoxins will increase its  sensitivity.
It will create many mast cells in the bladder wall.
Mast cells are most famous for
producing a lot of histamine.
Histamine will make your bladder very sensitive.
Just a little bit of water comes in,
and it wants to contract, it's raring to go.
And there's another type,
that responds poorly to conventional treatments.
Exactly.
Or, for example, they take some medication
that should improve certain symptoms,
but it doesn't.
I even have patients who take steroids
to reduce their allergies.
But after taking the steroids,
their allergies actually got worse.
Oh my god, so many things are popping into my head now.
What if, for example,
we now often use menopausal hormone therapy.
And they respond poorly to hormones.
Yes.
Is that also a possibility?
It's possible.
There's a special kind of mycotoxin
called Zearalenone.
Right, and another one is called Enniatin B
These two types of toxins
are ones that specifically affect hormones.
By this point, you should know
that mycotoxins don't just come from food.
So we've prepared for everyone
a comparison chart of mycotoxin sources and symptoms.
If you'd like to know,
click the link in the top right to get it.
Are there any mycotoxins that you frequently detect
in your clinical practice, some common ones?
There are two types of mycotoxins
that are detected at a particularly high rate.
The first is Gliotoxin.
Gliotoxin, as mentioned earlier,
is something produced by Candida or other molds.
Also, because its chemical structure contains
disulfide bonds, which are sulfides,
people who have strange reactions to eating sulfides,
like, for example, garlic,
onions,
or even cruciferous vegetables.
These are foods that we think of as super healthy,
great foods.
So if there is Gliotoxin,
whether in the nose and respiratory tract,
or the urogenital system,
or the gastrointestinal tract,
it means that somewhere in your body,
there is definitely mold.
The second one is called mycophenolic acid.
This represents that your external,
your current environment has mold.
This mycophenolic acid,
among all mycotoxins,
is the only one that is water-soluble.
Being water-soluble means
in theory, as long as you leave that environment,
your body should be able to metabolize it naturally.
But if the test result is very high,
it means your current environment,
is also somewhere...
there must be mold.
Oh, one is mold from the outside,
and one is mold from the inside.
You definitely have to find it.
Okay, I think after hearing this,
in front of the camera,
does everyone feel like
we  have mycotoxins in our  body, right?
So, generally, in terms of diet,
are there any key points that can help us to
strengthen these systems in our body?
Of course, the first thing is to quit sugar.
Sugar, for most molds,
has a nourishing effect.
Next is to consume more good oils.
Like olive oil,
black seed oil,
or some fish oils.
There are some better ones,
essential oils with sterilizing effects,
will also help to eliminate mycotoxins.
And also,
dietary fiber.
Oh, fiber.
It's actually very good.
And probiotics as well.
There are mainly a few probiotics that are particularly helpful.
Since you're already giving it good fiber,
it can act as a very good prebiotic.
For example, Lactobacillus.
And sometimes we target the allergy-prone group
by using Saccharomyces boulardii.
There is also a type called soil-based probiotics.
For eliminating mycotoxins,
it's actually particularly helpful.
Not bad, internal cleansing.
What about external?
Are there things in our environment
we should pay attention to,
to prevent mold from continuing to thrive?
For example, indoor potted plants,
and if you have some water leaks,
places with mold or mildew,
wall mold ,
this, of course, must be dealt with first.
What if you've looked everywhere and can't find it?
Then the simplest way
is actually to use an air purifier
and a dehumidifier.
Actually, research has found that
if the humidity is below 50%,
it can inhibit mold growth.
And I used to make mistakes myself.
Whenever I ordered packages,
Mmm.
I would just pile up the boxes there.
Right, because paper absorbs water easily.
So it tends to rot.
And even some,
some stricter mycotoxin experts abroad,
they all feel that you shouldn't have open bookshelves.
Bookshelves that can be closed would be better.
Because those books have also tested positive for aflatoxin before.
Oh my god.
My house has open bookshelves.
Looks like I need to go back and do a major cleanup.
I believe there are still many people who feel that
they eat very healthily,
and they haven't found anything suspicious at home.
But they still feel that mycotoxins are bothering them.
So in terms of treatment,
Dr. Wang has some more specialized steps
to help these people, right?
Yes.
The first step is still to recommend testing.
First, establish a diagnosis.
Each method of detoxification is completely different.
I have a total of four,
called the 4D Detox Therapy.
This is mentioned in my new book called
"Never Thought It Could Be Mold."
The first D is Drain.
Which is drainage.
Next is Detox.
Start detoxing.
The third is Desensitize.
Which is desensitization.
The last one is Drive.
Meaning you need to take control of your own life.
Actually, I have already finished reading this book.
It's very well written.
I think whether you're a member of the general public
or a professional,
if you want to understand mold,
I highly recommend everyone to read it.
And in it, I think for the general public,
what might be applicable is the part about essential oils.
Could you briefly talk about
how essential oils help with mold?
Because back then,
when I took those classes on mycotoxins,
they would all mention some essential oils.
Or later when I was reading  papers,
I also found that,
hey, many things for treating mycotoxins,
why are they only found in essential oils?
They can't be found in either diet or supplements.
For example, Palmarosa.
Its detoxification rate for Zearalenone
can reach 99%.
And another thing is,
for example, Oregano.
And also Cineole rosemary,
or Roman chamomile
plus true Lavender.
These two together, actually for Candida,
as long as the concentration is less than 1%,
it has an inhibitory effect on Candida.
So essential oils are actually for mold
or mycotoxins,
they have a very good detoxification effect.
Wow, that's great.
Actually, the things Dr. Wang mentioned
are written in the book.
It already teaches you some methods inside.
And actually, Dr. Wang, for this matter,
created an essential oil, right?
Yes, that's right.
This essential oil is called "Killed Mold 18 Spices".
It uses 18 essential oils.
If the symptoms are related to mold or mycotoxins,
I highly recommend it.
And especially for the first point I mentioned,
Drain, which is drainage,
I think it's particularly helpful.
How to use it for drainage?
Actually, it spreads very easily.
So just squeeze a little bit onto your hand.
Yes.
And spread it out a bit.
When you sleep, there is a
very important lymphatic system
called the glymphatic system.
It is closely related to our immune function.
So if we can, during sleep,
help this glymphatic system to drain,
you will sleep very well.
And it helps with detoxification.
Furthermore, it's very helpful for the cognitive function I mentioned earlier.
It's also very helpful.
Most studies are
focused on dementia and Alzheimer's disease.
It's very simple.
We can feel the front of our neck,
we can all feel a pulse, right?
This is the carotid artery.
Next to it is the jugular vein,
and the vagus nerve.
And the lymphatic system all run together.
So just simply use your hand
slowly towards the heart,
massage in a centripetal direction.
It doesn't need to be very forceful.
Actually, a gentle touch is enough.
This can have a detoxifying effect.
This is the first important point.
The second important point
is in this area.
This is called the transverse process of the first cervical vertebra.
It's behind the ear,
there's a hard part called the mastoid.
And between the mandible,
is a hollow point.
The hollow point that sinks in.
Here, because there are so many intersecting nerves,
many people feel sore when they press it.
It's also where the glymphatic system is most likely to get stuck.
So pressing here
can actually help with sleep
and help with the detoxification of the glymphatic system.
That's great, now we have something
very practical that we can do, right?
Yes, we can.
We can definitely eliminate mycotoxins.
I'm also very curious,
the extent of improvement in your symptoms later on.
I have improved dramatically.
My fatigue and allergies,
really, after treating the mycotoxins,
about 99% of them are gone.
So everyone,
can almost everyone achieve this kind of result?
Almost everyone can.
And I think treating mycotoxins is
very fulfilling for me.
And it also makes the patients very happy.
Of course, I'm not saying your fatigue and
nasal allergies
are definitely caused by mycotoxins.
Actually, as long as you find the right cause,
the treatment effect will be very good.
After hearing all this today,
everyone will realize that mold is not what you think it is.
The damage mycotoxins cause us
is also very extensive.
However, after listening, you also feel that
there are things that can help us improve our health.
So now go and look around your house.
See if there's anything in your house,
air conditioners, moldy corners,
wall mold, carpets,
any corner where mold might be found.
You are welcome to leave a comment below and share with us.
That can also help
viewers who might have the same problem as you.
Dr. Wang, thank you very much today.
And thank you all as well.
If you like our channel,
remember to subscribe, share, and like us.
Turn on the notification
We'll see you in the next episode. Bye-bye.